wir sind damit aus der konferenz unter
anderem mit gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach raus und wieder im deutschen
bundestag hier ist man mittlerweile beim
thema regionale lebensmittel angekommen
als geht um die vermarktung deutscher
lebensmittel die unionsfraktion hat hier
einen antrag eingereicht in dem sie
fordert dass es eine nationale agrar
marketing agentur gibt die eben
deutsche agrarprodukte im in und ausland
für diese wirkt so einer gab es übrigens
schon bis 2009 gab es so eine
marketingagentur die dann kampagnen
gemacht hat für fleisch milch eier obst
und gemüse aus deutschland
allerdings war die finanzierung wurde
für verfassungswidrig erklärt deswegen
wurde diese agentur eingestellt die
unionsfraktion wird eben jetzt dafür und
wir sind mitten in der rede von daher
ist schon die nächste rednerin von der
linksfraktion
ina hattendorf ist dass die sprecherin
der linksfraktion für landwirtschaft
ländliche räume und tierschutz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau dr spallek hat schon vieles gesagt
was ich auch sagen wollte aber dennoch
der vorliegende antrag fängt mit der
vermarktung regionaler lebensmittel gut
an und lässt dann aber mit ausbau der
agrarexporte stark nach ein ansinnen als
hätte es die zukunftskommission
landwirtschaft nie gegeben auch
aussuchen der exporttätigkeit wie hier
verlangt ist im zeitalter von
klimawandel und nachhaltigkeit nicht
angebracht wichtiger als mehr export
heimische lebensmittel zu fordern ist es
die weitgehende selbstversorgung in
deutschland herzustellen
dadurch würden kurz zulieferketten
ermöglicht und entsorgt von werkzeugen
bis zum konsumenten
der ausbau regionaler
verarbeitungs und
vermarktungsunternehmen wäre
selbstverständlich eine förderwürdige
idee aber der export auf teufel komm
raus über das maß hinaus das es jetzt
schon gibt da sagen wir nein nicht mit
uns
wir wollen gerade den grad der
selbstversorgung erhöhen dieser gibt
obst und gemüse wir haben es gerade
gehört nur bei 30 prozent apple aus
übersee durch subventionierte abkommen
sind zum teil billiger als die
heimischen aber sie sind ökologisch
fragwürdig lange lieferketten kühlung
lagerung usw im zweifel haben diese
äpfel natürlich nicht mehr vitamine und
nährstoffe als die heimischen aus dem
alten land und diese philosophie ist
übertragbar leinsamen stadt hier erbsen
stadt so ja wir müssen umstellen also
die stärkung der inlandsproduktion für
den heimischen markt das muss die devise
sein
viel dringender ist export anzukurbeln
muss die marktstellung der landwirte und
landwirtinnen verbessert werden den vier
größten händlern der lebensmittel des
lebensmitteleinzelhandels in der
vermarktung stehen etwa 200
63.500 landwirtschaftliche betriebe
gegenüber und wer diktiert den preis
nicht die landwirte der vorliegende
antrag ignoriert das notwendigste die
landwirtschaft braucht jetzt die
zusicherung dass die produkte nicht mehr
unterhalb der produktionskosten ab
verkauft und hier im land konsumiert
werden vielen dank für aufmerksamkeit
anna loos war das für die linksfraktion
und nächster redner in der debatte um
eine um die vermarktung regionaler
lebensmittel ist im boot wie er sitzt im
ausschuss für landwirtschaft und
ernährung für die fdp-fraktion und
spricht jetzt hier im deutschen
bundestag zum ersten mal
[Applaus]
sehr gerne frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
gestatten sie mir ein paar einleitenden
bemerkungen
es ist eine ganz besondere ehre für mich
hier an diesem platz zu stehen und zu
ihnen zu sprechen
am 10 november
1989 habe ich nur wenige meter von hier
am brandenburger tor mein ganz eigenes
stück von der mauer abgeschlagen
es war ein ganz besonderes gefühl
und heute hier zu stehen
ist noch einmal etwas
besonderes
zu bieten
auch in unsere diesem vorliegend antrag
die cdu csu fordert dass eine staatliche
agrar marketing agentur gegründet werden
soll um deutsche produkte der land und
ernährungswirtschaft
verstärkt international auf eu-ebene und
weltweit zu bewerben
bekanntlich sind unsere hochwertigen
lebensmittel im in und ausland sehr
geschätzt und es gibt weltweit kaum ein
land das eine solche
lebensmittelqualität im einklang mit
derartig hohen standort tirol
nachhaltigkeit erzeugt wie deutschland
die fdp hat gemeinsam mit ihren
koalitionspartnern im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart den anteil regionaler
erzeugnisse entsprechend der ausbauziele
zu erhöhen wir wollen unsere verbraucher
und deutschland noch stärker motivieren
regional erzeugte deutsche lebensmittel
zu kaufen es ist nicht nur im sinne des
verbrauchers im feinkostladen
deutschland einzukaufen
sondern nutzt auch
unsere bauern
die forderung im antrag die errichtung
einer agrar marketing agentur nach dem
vorbild azéma
bekanntlich müsste die centrale
marketing-gesellschaft nach dem urteil
des bundesverfassungsgerichts im jahr
2009 liquidiert werden weil ein privat
finanziert exportförderung mit
zwangsabgaben als nicht
verfassungskonform
beachtet wurde sehr geehrte damen und
herren der union
ich frage mich
warum haben sie unter der
unionsgeführten bundesregierung nicht
schon längst eine nachfolgeorganisation
für die cma
installiert
warum haben sie die letzten 13 jahre
regierungsverantwortung mit
agrarministern von cdu und csu nicht
genutzt um eine neue staatlich
finanzierten marke vermarktung im sinne
dieses antrags aufzubauen
warum stellen sie dann gerade jetzt aus
der parlamentarischen opposition heraus
diese forderung
ich kann es ihnen sagen sie
wussten dass sie aus bundesmitteln nicht
finanzierbar worden sie wussten schon
damals dass der einzelplan des
bundesministeriums für ernährung und
landwirtschaft um 100 millionen euro pro
jahr aufgestockt werden müsste
auch die restmittel in höhe von 100
millionen euro aus der liquidation der
absatzfonds der cma dürfte allenfalls
für eine anschubfinanzierung reichen die
laufen die eigentlichen kosten liegen
dann aber auch bei etwa 100 millionen
natürlich ist das aus der opposition
sicht komfortabel eine derartige
forderung zu stellen ohne darzulegen wo
das geld dafür herkommen soll ich
vermisse im vorliegend antrag ein
seriöses finanzierungskonzept
die fdp steht für bürokratieabbau und
entlastung der bürger
mit der gründung einer staatlich
finanzierten ak marketingagentur dann
wieder eine neue behörde mit vier neuen
bundesbeamten geschaffen und damit
steuern in millionenhöhe
versenkt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der union
die antrag hört sich zunächst sehr wohl
klingen dann ist aber bei genauer
betrachtung
eine politische luftnummer
jetzt eine forderung aufzustellen
von der sie seit 13 jahren in der
regierung wussten dass sie aus
bundesmitteln nicht zu finanzieren ist
hat nichts aber auch gar nichts mit
einer konstruktiven oppositionsarbeit zu
tun viel schlimmer
mit solchen anträgen für tun als ob
nicht eher die letzten eineinhalb jahre
und jahrzehnte für die landwirtschaft
verantwortung getragen hat ist lange
noch nicht in der rolle opposition in
diesem hohen hause an die kunden vielen
dank
vielen dank
als nächste hält das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion die kollegin christina
stump und es ist ihre erste rede im
deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
hochwertige aber bezahlbare lebensmittel
nicht nur mehr wertschätzung sondern
wertschöpfung für die bäuerinnen und
bauern schöne worte die der minister in
seiner agenda hat fallen lassen das
unterschreibe ich gerne aber wie das
funktionieren kann dazu schweigt der
minister
dabei liegt die lösung war deutlich nach
nichts liegt näher als lebensmittel aus
der unmittelbaren region der menschen
der landwirtschaft oder land wurde vor
ort produziert der landwirt vor ort
produziert hochwertige erzeugnisse und
steht für ihre qualität mit seinem guten
namen als jemand der auf einem
landwirtschaftlichen familienbetrieb
groß geworden ist weiß ich mit wie viel
engagement herzblut und innovativen
ideen hier gearbeitet wird
regionalität bedeutet auch kurze
transportwege
das ist ökologisch sinnvoll und spart
zugleich kosten direkte vermarktung und
weniger zwischenhändler bedeuten mehr
geld für unsere landwirte
qualitätsprodukte aus der region das ist
es auch was sich unsere verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher heute wünschen
82 prozent sagen dass die regionale
herkunft von lebensmitteln ein wichtiges
auswahlkriterium bei ihrer
kaufentscheidung darstellt diese chance
wollen wir nutzen
regionale lebensmittel genießen erstens
bei den verbraucherinnen verbraucher ein
hohes maß an vertrauen sie stehen
zweitens für transparenz frische und
qualität und drittens noch
entscheidender sie stärken die
wertschöpfung in den ländlichen regionen
und tragen zur erhalt unserer
kulturlandschaft bei über gutes von hier
gut reden das muss unser ansatz sein
in der kommunikation entlang der
wertschöpfungsketten vom erzeuger bis
zum verbraucher können und müssen die
vorzüge unserer heimischen
landwirtschaft
hervorkommen und damit verbundenen
mehrwert noch stärker betont werden dass
mehr an qualität an genuss an frische
ist aber auch ein mehr an arbeit wie das
positiv begleitet werden kann konnte ich
an meiner alten wirkungsstätte sehen das
cdu-geführte
landwirtschaftsministerium in baden
württemberg hat bereits 2017 die
regional kampagne natürlich von daheim
gestattet die landwirtschaft bekommt
hier ein gesicht und wird für den
verbraucher erlebbar gemacht
meine damen und herren ein wichtiger
ansatz für uns als cdu csu fraktion zur
stärkung unserer agrar und
ernährungswirtschaft ist neben dem
ausbau regionaler wertschöpfungsketten
auch die erschließung neuer märkte im
ausland
gerade unseren kleinen und mittleren
landwirtschaftlichen betrieben wollen
wir bei der vermarktung ihrer
hochwertigen lebensmittel unterstützen
deshalb brauchen wir eine agrar
marketing agentur die den
qualitätsstand in germany auch über
unserer landwirtschaft leuchten lässt
liebe damen und herren
wir stärken mit unserem antrag die
zukunftsfähigkeit unserer höfe und
sorgen zugleich dafür dass hochwertige
lebensmittel in zukunft auch bezahlbar
bleiben
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau kollegin
und als nächste erhält das wort
natalie public und auch für sie ist es
die erste rede im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren
als ich in meinen ersten sechs
lebensjahren im tiefsten sibirien auf
einem kleinen selbstversorger bauernhof
aufgewachsen bin hätte sich niemand aus
meiner familie auch noch vorstellen
können dass ich einmal meine erste rede
im deutschen bundestag zur agrarpolitik
halten
die wenigsten landwirte heute sind wie
wir damals selbstversorger doch noch
immer ist die regionale landwirtschaft
in ihrer vielfalt eine tragende säule
unserer gesellschaft tag für tag
versorgen uns menschen in der
landwirtschaft mit lebensmitteln die
meisten betriebe sind
familienunternehmen sie gestalten den
ländlichen raum wie kein anderer
wirtschaftszweig
in meinem wahlkreis denn der hessischen
wetter auch finden sie zahlreiche
betriebe die clevere ideen der direkt
vermarktung ihrer produkte umsetzen und
nicht aufhören sich zu entwickeln um
gute landwirtschaftliche erzeugnisse an
die konsumenten zu bringen nur gemeinsam
mit den landwirtinnen und landwirten als
partner schaffen wir es die
herausforderungen des klimawandels
unserer zeit zu die welt
ich bin froh dass wir mit der neuen
koalition und dem personalwechsel an der
spitze des bundesministeriums für
ernährung und landwirtschaft den fokus
endlich wieder auf eine sozial gerechte
ökonomisch und ökologisch zukunftsfähige
landwirtschaft legen
wir machen fortschrittliche politik auf
höhe der zeit weil wir landwirtschaft
und klimaschutz zusammenführen und sie
mit einer fortschrittlichen politik
verbinden statt gegeneinander
auszuspielen
[Applaus]
der klimawandel und internationale
lieferketten verlangen gerade von den
familiengeführten betrieben viel ab es
ist wichtig dass wir als bundesrepublik
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern
nachhaltigkeit fähre handels und
produktionsbedingungen und soziale
standards in der landwirtschaft
europäisch und global voranbringen
preisdumping und unfaire
handelsbedingungen raum die
existenzgrundlagen sowohl dem bauern in
deutschland als auch denjenigen deren
märkte mit exzessiven agrarexporten
überflutet werden staatlich geförderter
agrarexport mangels eigener
absatzmöglichkeit zerstört viel zu oft
regionale märkte ein massiver ausbau von
agrarexporten verschärft die probleme
gerade in den ländern des globalen
südens es ist kein beitrag zur lösung
was mich aber noch viel mehr stört dass
ihre unreflektierte haltung zu ergreifen
orten liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
cdu csu in den letzten 16 jahren wurde
das bundesministerium für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
durchgehend durch ihre partei besetzt 16
jahre in denen sie zeit gehabt hätten
die sozialen bedingungen in der
landwirtschaft zu verbessern das massive
höfesterben zu stoppen und für mehr
nachhaltigkeit zu sorgen
hätte frau klöckner in der letzten
legislatur auf das ein oder andere
treffen mit messi und co verzichtet und
stattdessen politik für die regionale
landwirtschaft gemacht dann wären wir
heute einen großen schritt weiter
es ist gut dass die ampel koalition eine
wende aus ihrer veralteten politik
einläutet und gemeinsam mit der
landwirtschaft für fortschritt sorgt
herzlichen dank für ihre auch noch
die erste hürde von kelly pavlik aus der
spd-fraktion sie unter anderem wie das
system der landwirtschaft angesprochen
hat auch das ist hier immer wieder thema
wie auch die landwirte unterstützt
werden können dass sie gut entlohnt
werden für ihre arbeit wir kommen zur
letzten rede in dieser debatte dass er
ist max straubinger von der
unionsfraktion
diese frau präsidentin werden die
kolleginnen und kollegen und kolleginnen
public sie sind da die letzten jahre
nicht dabei gewesen auch unter der
ständig die spd begleitet als er ende
regierungsarbeit und da haben wir in der
regel nur erlebt dass wenn es um
internationale abkommen ging wenn zum
tabu wenn zum tipp geben wenn es um die
abkommen mit japan ging letztendlich die
spd immer auf der bremse stand kann
damit ging natürlich an wien export nix
weiter patrick kolleginnen und kollegen
kann jetzt ist es geht es uns auch und
den agrarexport der enorm wichtig ist
für uns für die bäuerinnen und bauern
ein dritter ein dritter der produzierten
güter gehen in den export und das
bedeutet aber nicht dass wir die
exportmärkte überschwemmen würden
sondern im gegenteil der import von
agrarprodukten ist wesentlich höher ist
mit der export in deutschland und das
ist mit die entscheidende frage und das
hilft auch entwicklungsländern frau
kollegin künast und da gehört mit dazu
dass wir natürlich werbung betreiben für
unsere hochqualitativen lebensmittel ich
erinnere daran es gibt den schönen
spruch wer nicht wirbt stirbt und das
bedeutet letztendlich mit einer
agrarmarketing struktur können wir hier
unterstützt für unsere lebensmittel
werden und dementsprechend grundlagen
schaffen für unsere bäuerinnen und
bauern dass sie eine gute existenz mit
haben können und dies haben wir mit den
vergangenen jahren heraus zustande
gebracht ich erinnere an werbesprüche
wie zb aus deutschen landen frisch auf
den tisch also das bedeutet regionalität
für uns für die bürgerinnen und bürgern
hohe qualität ich erinnere an den
schönen und guten spruch werden die
grünen natürlich nicht mittragen aber
ich stehe dazu fleisch ist ein stück
lebenskraft dies ist ein maler das war
mit etwas sehr wichtiges und
entscheidendes für vorlesungen
aminosäuren in der veganen ernährung und
sonst und zusätzlich tätigen muss ist es
besser also hier ein stück fleisch zu
konsumieren liebe frau kollegin kühn
austritt zu machen
und das bedeutet auch dass der export
und nachhaltige
lebensmittel erzeugung keine gegensätze
sind sondern im gegenteil es geht ja
darum zum beispiel bei einem stück
fleisch oder ein
schwein zu vermarkten da geht es um alle
teile wenn in deutschland die bürger
hauptsächlich schnitzel konsumieren
wollen so muss ich eben feststellen dass
ein ganzes schwein nicht nur schnitzel
besteht dazu gemalt und das egal ich
muss auch sagen wir hier ist es
offensichtlich nicht und das bedeutet
letztendlich das größer klaren füßchen
und sonstiges das in anderen entfernten
märkten
gerne aufgenommen wird dementsprechend
dann auch bedient werden müssen diese
märkte und das ist unser agrarexport der
damit eine unterstützung bekommen würde
deshalb kann ich werd ich kolleginnen
und kollegen der regierungsfraktionen
und vor allen dingen auch den kollegen
der fdp die sind ja früher auf serbien
agrarexport gewesen leider gottes wird
der kollege der für die fdp
geschlossen hatte aufgelegt also ich bin
noch völlig verdutzt gewesen keine
unterstützung mehr für die deutschen
bäuerinnen und bauern sondern im
gegenteil abbruchunternehmen hat sich
die fdp hier generierte die bäuerinnen
und bauern das ist letztlich die
konsequenz und deshalb stimmen sie
unserem antrag zu dann tun sie was gutes
für die bäuerinnen und bauern in
deutschland
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlage auf drucksache 206 an die in der
tagesordnung aufgeführten ausschüsse
vorgeschlagen gibt es weil es bedeutet
dort wird der antrag dann nochmal
diskutiert und dann wieder hier ins
plenum eingriff so diskutiert